Sall I heard you're upset about
mitigation right my big concern is that
Donald Trump you know he's always
concerned about opening the economy
opening economy setting dates but we're
not mitigating we're not staying
contained and when you say we're not
mitigating a give me an example
mitigating means staying away from
people staying together staying enclosed
Prell Avene being aware if you could
talk about mitigating a little bit maybe
people will listen to you I think you
have a good message finally it's common
sense just mitigate you need to mitigate
that means stop going out wear your
masks stay quarantine stay at home
mitigate mitigate yeah right I mean I
watch dr. Burks and she's talking about
mitigation every five seconds she's like
mitigation is important what is
mitigation mean if mitigation is
important I would I would assume that
mitigation means that you have to
quarantine yourself and stay safe have
you ever assumed anything and been wrong
are your kids mitigating yes my children
are in mitigation right now yes so we
can't even see them because they're in
mitigation while they're in their rooms
they're actually being homeschooled
right now they're on their iPads and
they're mitigating and within the house
are your parents mitigating yeah we're
all mitigating I I watch the [ __ ]
news what else could it possibly mean
have you ever heard of a dictionary do
you ever look up the words when you dr.
Burke don't you know not to try out new
words by now seriously I mean after all
the trouble you've had on the air I
would pick out 30 to 40 words that I
knew really well I had him down solid
and stick with those and that would be
I'd be like I'd walk around like tars
and say me like warranty no no there's
your wife she just was can I just tell
you how sorry I am for you man you
married this out
listening myself to say it's kind of
more honest talking that's why I mean I
don't like being in the house I can't be
myself is he practicing good mitigation
yes yes too much too much
[Laughter]